die chancen sehr entspannt aus diese
position hält was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video leute
ich hoffe natürlich jedes gut wir haben
heute mal wieder was cooles tor habe ich
vorher so noch nie gemacht das ganze
entstand wieder durch die idee eines
zuschauers ich habe nämlich eine mail
bekommen von einem amazon produkttester
glaube ich jetzt nichts besonderes so es
gibt viele amazonen produkttester und
ich glaube auch jeder kann das werden
falls ich mich jetzt nicht irre der name
sagt eigentlich schon alles du bekommst
produkte umsonst zugeschickt kannst du
dann testen musste rezensionen schreiben
und darf sie behalten so weit ich weiß
du darfst sie aber nicht selber weiter
verkaufen stellt euch vielleicht auch
was aus der mail ein auf jeden fall hat
er sich bei mir gemeldet und meint er
hat einige von meinen unboxing videos
gesehen leider war bei den amazonen
sachen ja immer nur schrott bei der hat
mir versprochen er hat super viele
sachen zu hause von wirklich guten
marken kein china schrott und hat mir
angeboten ich solle 300 euro überweisen
der ball hat mir ein paket rüber mit
mindestens 800 euro warenwert aber
wahrscheinlich sogar deutlich mehr
naja wie dem auch sei ein park ist schon
da das andere kommt erst morgen hermes
lässt wieder auf sich warten lasse diese
leute ok nein das war nicht fair wir
haben auch einen anstrengenden job
deswegen ich respektiere das und müssen
runter länger warten aber das hauptpaket
ist da und das werden wir jetzt mal
zusammen auf machen so gespannt es wird
auf jeden fall glaube ich geil sonst bin
ich nämlich sauer auf ihn und will meine
300 euro wider und ich habe sogar seine
adresse und ich pfeif ich bei amazon
wenn da nicht die eines sohnes dann
war's das mit einer test karriere mein
freund auch nur ein spaß leute ihr kennt
mich so was würde ich niemals machen ja
also das hier weg im moment hier steht
so oft raus zehn kilogramm also hier
muss schon mal gut was drin sein dann
bin ich mal gespannt ob die worte vom
amazon produkttester aus stimmen und wir
machen dass man auch mal wieder leistung
und jetzt habe ich schon in die erste
verpackung reingeschnitten öffne mich
erst zum schluss was gefällt mir doch
schon mal leute hier da steht drauf das
muss ich sagen feiere ich sowas hatte
ich glaube ich erst einmal dann öffne
ich dich erst zum schluss vielleicht ist
da noch einen gutschein drinnen oder so
ich hab mir gedacht wir machen das heute
mal so ihr könnt ja auch perfekt von
oben mit rein schauen aber häufig keine
zweite kamera stadler mit der ersten
marke hier haben wir zb true weil es ihr
bad wo sie das ganze aus preise sind
immer direktion mit eingeblendeter hat
mir gesagt es werden keine standard
china design sowie es sonst immer war
hier hinten steht jetzt natürlich die
asn drauf von amazon und der erste
eindruck ja profis ist schon ein
hochwertigeres produkt was bestimmt
denke ich mal 40 50 euro kosten kann
vielleicht auch sogar mehr und das ist
noch frisch eingepackt also danke der ja
auf jeden fall dafür sollte weiter geht
das ist leider nicht so gut wenn ihr
meine videos regelmäßig schaut dann
wisst ihr dass sich solche verpackungen
gar nicht leiden kann ich hatte wirklich
als ich diese 1100 euro amazon pakete
bestellt habe da waren so viele artikel
drinnen die genau so verpackt sind und
da weiß so ganz genau das ist irgendein
china kam den irgendein amazon fbi
verkäufer nach deutschland geholt hat
und hier haben wir usb-ports ok keine
ahnung erfahrungsgemäß kann ich sagen
kriegt man dafür vielleicht 20 euro
leicht auch 30 weiß ich jetzt nicht
genau muss ich gleich mal googeln hier
sind einem preis zwischen eingeblendet
mein gott und das ist erst das erste
paket morgen kommt wie gesagt nur eins
von hermes das ist wahrscheinlich nicht
geil als dies aber das kommt auch noch
hinzu jetzt wieder halt ihr könnt sie in
made in china wider sondern standard
china produkt macht das mal kurz hier
hinten auf okay finde ich lustig also
das produkt ist ein bisschen größer
denke mal der fußball wird leuchten wenn
man ihnen hier drauf legt deswegen das
testen direktwahl vielleicht behalte ich
das ja auch selber weil er kennt nicht
ich bin fußballfan durch und durch das
ist übrigens keine landen magnetisch ist
also wahrscheinlich ist es wenn es
dunkel ist auch ein landwirt aber guck
mal das ist wirklich schwierig habe mir
gerade extra tutorial angestaut man muss
ganz ganz vorsichtig wir diesen markt
ihr diesen optimal über menschen und
finden damit der ball
okay leute jetzt haben es geschafft aber
kannst es nochmal machen bitte einmal
sehen dass die minister johanna hallo
alles wird ja und jetzt hat es mal
wieder ja
sehr gut
so sieht das ding aus ich weiß nicht ob
das jetzt so besonders ist
darunter ist einfach noch ein päckchen
drin bund so vertraut ist bin ich mal
gespannt weil in sofa kann ja schlecht
drin sein ok weiter geht's mit diesem
gaming headset pro gaming headset von
teja das patent für der marke auch auf
jeden fall standard ein bisschen fpl
produkt trotzdem leicht mache ich mach
das mal auf clara für mädels oder obwohl
man muss ja auch qualitativ ist das auf
jeden fall nicht schlecht mit war jetzt
höre ich gar nichts mehr ja ich sehe aus
wie so ein fluglotse
[Musik]
was live is life also hiermit stelle ich
mich irgendwann heißes trainerin vor so
oder die haben doch alle doping- gehetzt
also ein bisschen ausschnitt viel spaß
leute dazu kann ich auf jeden fall mal
kurz die story erzählen nicht war vor
zwei wochen bin ich in urlaub geflogen
für eine woche nach kreta griechenland
wir sind von dortmund aus geflogen waren
drei stunden vor am flughafen weil wir
noch unser gepäck aufgeben mussten die
schlange zu der körper abgabe war
unmenschlich lange dagegen gar nicht es
war viel zu wenig personal am flughafen
und ich kam halt einfach gar nicht voran
und irgendwann standen wir da ist war
halb drei und unserer fliegen hat um 15
uhr haben wir gefragt hey wir müssen da
jetzt hin wir können meinten die nähe
geht noch nicht berufen euch gleich vor
falls das notwendig ist wir stehen da
ist es fehle vor drei immer noch nichts
passiert wir gehen da wieder hin die
sagen jetzt aber schnell ihr müsst nach
vorne direkt zum schalter drängen euch
an allen vorgibt einen kopf ab wir gehen
dahin wollen unseren koffer abgeben
sonst hätten die mine die maschine ist
jetzt leider schon zu ihr müsst damit
jetzt richtig security line also wenn
man so durch das security links geht ne
die rennen mit diesen fetten koffer zu
security check in die sagen ihr müsst
damit zum anderen check-in der passt
hier nicht durch dann wären zum anderen
schrecken an allen vorbei dann wären zum
anderen checken an allen vorbei müssen
komplett den ganzen körper da waren
flüssigkeiten und so können die gegner
nicht mit ins handgepäck mussten wir
schmeißen puffer im wert von mehreren
hundert euro weil alle bei uns hat er
eingepackt haben wir waren zu zehn
unterwegs dann wir springen dadurch der
fluglotse schon wenn deine freunde weil
ich war der erste bin eine freundin in
einer minute sind ich mache den flieger
dichter fliegt ohne euch wohl
unfreundlich halt obwohl wir da gar
nichts für konnten ich stehe also total
nervös dann kam so einen funkspruch von
piloten ist ja noch mal herr kunze kein
stress alles entspannt wir haben noch
zeit so und dann dachte ich so ok alles
gut also herr kunze wassermann aber es
war wirklich knapp und deswegen halt
jetzt kurz hier die story mit dem
fluglotsen vielleicht hat es ja wer von
euch interessiert machen wir weiter hier
haben wir kick sie sind wahrscheinlich
oder sind das keks wird sind sogar noch
haltbar bis zum ersten drittel 2022 her
vielleicht so leute ich glaube ihr könnt
auch schon sehen hier haben wir einfach
ein headset von razer ohne scheiß
megageil das ist ja so oftmals insos cam
videos wo leute sagen und mystery box
bestellt jo in der razer headsets raus
irgendwelche handys in einem amazon
paket hatte ich so was geiles doch nie
deswegen danke dafür und das hat ja
wirklich auch wärt ihr seht zu eigen
wenn das wird er bestimmt 150 200 euro
kostet oder barracuda xt 100 aber
immerhin weiter geht's mit escape
massage augen massage also das muss ich
auch mal testen es ist doch auch wieder
so ein china produkt aber gut hochwertig
verpackt das muss man sagen dass man
sagen okay das ding kostet 80 euro das
ist auf jeden fall schon mal eine ansage
wenn es geiles behalte ich viele
schreiben ja mal ich hab so augenringe
vielleicht gehen ja davon weg wenn ich
das jeden tag aufsätze
egal was passiert hier alter hört ihr
das ja das kann man hören ich habe ja
ein mikrofon an
aber wer hat diesen scheiß ausgeht da
kommen auch so sounds da ihr hört das ja
so ein paar vögel zwitschern darum aber
was soll das bringen täglich angenehm
das ist alles andere als angenehm dass
muss ich noch mal genauer unter die lupe
nehmen eine sache habe ich noch hier
unten drin jetzt habe ich auch gecheckt
das ist kein sofa das ist eine sofa
lampe eine stehlampe müssen auch mal
kurz aufmachen nähe ich las dass da drin
weil das würde ich jetzt nicht testen
das verkauft ihr auf jeden fall weil
damit kann ich nichts anfangen es ist
kein ventilator leute es ist einfach nur
eine lampe hier ihr könnt euch einmal
noch anschauen wo sie das dringen aus
eine sunset lane jetzt schauen wir aber
mal wie teuer das ganze ist ich finds
leider auf die schnelle nicht ihr habt
den preis ich schon gesehen morgen kommt
noch das zweite paket an das werden wir
dann auch noch auspacken hier sonst
schon mal der zwischenstand wie viel wir
aktuell haben und denen darf ich ja auch
dann wahrscheinlich erst morgen öffnen
ich mache jetzt erstmal mittagspause wir
haben eine nur perfekt bis jetzt bin ich
auf jeden fall schon mal zufrieden du
kannst mir gerne öfter was schicken
leute und was ich direkt auch mal anti
sein kann am sonntag kommt glaube ich
ein geisteskranker video es wird ein
fettes projekt geben und ich glaube wenn
ich das so durchziehen dann habe ich in
vier monaten falls das so läuft wie ich
mir erhoffe ein zweites auto mein
lieblingsauto leute was glaube ich hoffe
da jetzt nichts zerbrechliches drin wir
haben schon den nächsten tag das paket
ist gerade angekommen also der
produkttester meint für dieses paket ist
auf jeden fall weniger wert als das
andere aber wir schauen jetzt mal rein
die irgendwie so aus als wäre dann nur
eine lampe drin kann hass unter diesem
paket ihr habt vielleicht gerade schon
gesehen liegt wieder so ein riesen
saturn dingen wie geht das denn auch das
ist nämlich der startschuss für ein
neues projekt was am sonntag vermutlich
online komplette hier ist ja nur seine
riesigen ring leuchte drin für die decke
wobei die ist schon stylish das muss man
sagen hier kann man das glaube ich ganz
gut erkennen so soll das aussehen ich
weiß ich bin mir unsicher ob die hier
reinpassen könnte kann man ja mal
überlegen ihr könnt ja mal in die
kommentare schreiben was er denkt und
das war es leider schon jetzt ist die
frage kommen wir damit wirklich auf 800
oder vielleicht sogar 1000 euro so wie
es mir versprochen hat und bevor ich es
vergesse wir hatten ja noch einen zettel
dabei öffne mich erst im schlussteil
rein vielleicht ist er ja auch noch was
cooles drin oder da stehen halt einfach
nur die ganzen produkte drauf und die
preise dazu das kann auch sein
okay ich bin euch hier auf jeden fall
ein foto vor dem schreiben eigentlich
ein scanner alex fehlen dem dank für
dein entgegengebrachte vertrauen ich
hoffe dass du mit diesen teilweise sehr
außergewöhnlichen produkten einen spaß
haben willst und vielleicht hast du ja
für das ein oder andere produkt eine
verwendung ansonsten wünsche ich dir
dass du einen guten gewinn erzielen
kannst deine videos sind sehr
unterhaltsam macht bitte weiter so ja
ich danke dir auf jeden fall hat spaß
gemacht und wenn du nochmal coole sachen
ist schreibt mir auf jeden fall
insgesamt kommen wir jetzt laut ihm auf
843 er wollte 300 euro für das paket
haben also für mich auf jeden fall ein
gutes geschäft auch wenn ich natürlich
weiß das ist das ein oder andere davon
nicht so einfach los werde aber
irgendwie wird das schon oder ich
verschenkt sonst wobei das razer headset
das bekommt ihr jemand von euch schreibt
einfach an coolen kommentaren in
stellungnahmen dazu und dann gebe ich
das auf instagram bekannt heißt hier
alex wie das gleiche auch bei dem iphone
8 aus dem letzten minuten takt auf jeden
fall ins überhaupt das ist einfach
leichter wenn ich da kurzem eine story
posten gewonnen hat danke auf jeden fall
fürs zuschauen leute abonniert super
gerne den kanal und seid gespannt
sonntag auf das video ist wird zu wild
und ich hoffe dass das klappt das wäre
auf jeden fall ein geisteskranker das
projekt haut rein machst ja auch